I can't control whether you're husband
and wife will live or die or get sick or
leave you or get a divorce I don't want
any of that that than any human being I
hate suffering I do anything I can tell
people's not suffer but I can't control
that you can you can there are people
have lost their arms lost their sight
there have been people that have been to
the most horrific experiences of life
and they found a way to still be happy
because they've made the decision that
life is too short to suffer and the way
I get out of suffering I give myself a
90 second rule it's really simple
I say look I feel myself starting to
feel that stress doing that pissed off
this or upsetness or concern or worry
but I get whenever I realize that's not
going to make it better
life's too short to suffer and then I
just kind of breathe slowly slow
everything down I just watch the car go
by look at that crazy not really that
crazy that's uber said I thought I'm
gonna kill that son of a [ __ ] right and
then you don't kill him could you don't
believe that mom it's the thoughts that
are stressful that you believe that
that's left when you question them you
break the pattern
you